et de voir quelqu'un qui malgré tout
depuis dix ans 12 ans fabrique la télé
est réussie on se régale drucker
tunisien un peu trop de chamois à merci
gg ça me fait extrêmement plaisir ma
chérie taxe est sincère mais c'est
surtout à la raison faut te reconnaître
avec la d'autres défauts mais pour
reconnaître que revenir avec les boîtes
revenir avec tutu sans les choses sans
les choses à la télé tu sens le rythme
du sens des choses voilà merci mes
chéris et tout cas je voudrais remercier
c'est surtout les téléspectateurs aussi
qui nous soutiennent à fond et qui sont
là dans tous nos projets merci mais chez
on a décidé de vous régaler aussi chez
vous avec l'enseigne but pour fêter la
dernière de la saison vous allez sur le
compte twitter de tp pour gagner des
cadeaux toutes les minutes
il ya smartphones tablettes consoles de
jeux télé robot de cuisine je tenais à
remercier particulièrement jessica
empereur caroline saint-aubin ainsi que
toutes les équipes de cette enseigne qui
nous accompagnent m'a donné tous les
cadeaux et ça continue sur twitter même
pendant à prendre ou à laisser voulait
voir et m'ont regardé raymond qui a été
relooké raymond et regarder qui va
défiler dans la rue ça lui va
salut
par ailleurs les sondages eh ben ça me
paraît bien voilà merci